hello, how are you, sal y jaramillo greetings
with the brief information for today, tuesday,
may 18, there are two
big events involving the mayor of
norte los vigueses, young lee, yesterday he
confirmed running for governor
after changing the
republican party and also announced that
tested positive decoder says he is
complying with his quarantine that he
feels fine and that he does not have any
symptoms being that being that
a job fair is being organized today he is looking to hire
sales personnel, reception, security and
workers in the playground this
event will be of  10 in the morning to 5 in the
afternoon inside the hotel if you are interested
you can fill out the application on their
official website first dress to impress
since you could be hired today
also today by quincy come yen they are
organizing a job fair this is
from  11 a.m. to 3 p.m.
inside the salon in benin looking to
hire full-time
and part-time staff for  could be hired
today you will have to wear your mask to
enter the place and also they will not
charge you for parking if
you attend this event
now we pass with their
weather forecast a sunny day is expected the
temperatures will rise to the 90s and by the
end of the week they will drop  likewise
the wind will return tomorrow have a
good day i am salt and jaramillo with his
brief informative for kirchner in
spanish
[Music]